oh my god who is she that doesn't even
look like me
oh I forgot to put deodorant on guys
hold on Instagram moms they're beautiful
they're positive their lives are
absolutely perfect but that's not me but
I want to know what it takes to be an
Instagram mom and I want a sneak peek
into that life so I'm gonna try
something for one week I'm going to be
the ultimate Instagram mom I'm gonna
have to figure everything out the hair
the makeup the smiling children how do
you even make those do they come out
like that I don't understand but I'm
gonna give it a try so wish me luck I
think first we should establish what an
Instagram mom is if you saw one you
would know exactly what I'm talking
about she posts perfect pictures I'd say
my Instagram is a trash fire it's very
cluttered just very much my real life
when I had my oldest son I was 22 single
mom a complete mess and just had such a
hard time transitioning into Parenthood
and I'm looking at all these moms on my
phone just dressed to the nines and
perfect with these perfect lives and it
made me feel like crap about myself
and it took me years and years to
overcome that feeling of being
inadequate so this is gonna be really
really really hard for me I actually
found out that a lot of these accounts
achieve these consistently perfect posts
by block shooting there will be one
Saturday morning photo shoot they'll get
you know enough photos for the next 1 to
2 weeks and it's usually taken by a
professional photographer so I met with
John BuzzFeed's professional
photographer
like stock photos thank you all right
Emily like stockpile photos there's two
sides to it I think there are real moms
out there that have Instagram accounts
that are showing their real life and
they are like actually giving tips to
moms and stuff like that then there's
like the whole fabricated perfect life
mom and like I can't really get down
with that like I feel like we might have
to do more planning on this natural
shoot than I do on like a real photo
shoot so the crew shows up for the photo
shoot my house is a mess because I don't
know I live in it I live with two
children I'll clean when they move out
to get my makeup done there's no way
that these people do their own makeup
that well for these Instagram photo
shoots the entire day I just bribed my
kids with treats I could not get my kids
to do this any other way here and if
your kid gives you that like oh it was a
lot of that boy teeny socks this is
exhausting anything gets their kids to
actually like put up with this a better
mom than I am
does this look normal no Cameron okay
I can't look serious in a picture like
it's so uncomfortable for me I feel like
an idiot there are people like trying to
walk their dog down the sidewalk I'm out
here like I'd say the majority of the
shots are me having a really hard time
posing I don't know how to do it and I
look like I'm trying to poop if I make
any other expression besides smiling it
literally looks like constipation I
ended up with two thousand photos so the
next task is to determine which ones I'm
actually going to post
oh my god just me I read Oh what's over
there oh I can't I can't tell I like
them or I hate them like they're really
good pictures they just it doesn't look
like me in it I look like I'm a life
coach
I'm here with John again he's retouching
some of the photos in the meantime this
is what I look like now but John's
making me look like oh my god she looks
fine from the beginning so I'm really
not doing much you know I guess I am
actually so let's go through the photos
we posted well it's really funny because
when you scroll on my Instagram now you
can see like it's normal normal normal
and then it comes to a screeching halt
and all of a sudden it's like perfect
kicking things off with a Saturday
morning coffee pick outfit number one
this is like fall mornings at home can I
just have time to like throw this on and
have some coffee
this is a photo I saw on a lot of
accounts and I just wanted to see what
it felt like it felt like nothing I
don't actually have any coffee you know
it looks beautiful but if you zoom out
my kids are actually on the couch
playing tablets so that they'll be quiet
and I can actually sit and get that shot
which one goes first the one that you're
looking at the camera
no oh you've got an Instagram they like
when you look away I couldn't decide
between three so I posted all three
because I've noticed there are a lot of
parasols happening on Instagram
mom accounts and one of them I'm
touching my hair because I guess you're
supposed to do that when you're happy
it's a ridiculous photo now it's time to
write a caption what's
like perfect people enjoy the morning
it's a caption so long that you need to
click more so caption day 1 is coming in
hot I decided to go big or go home
Saturday mornings the warm sunshine
peeking through my French doors the
joyous giggles of my boys meeting their
morning books and my husband whistling
softly to himself while he makes me an
omelette it's times like these that
remind me to stop and smell the coffee
hashtag mom life so this caption huh
it's just like the opposite of my
morning's no sunshine kids fighting I'm
making the omelets or usually it's
cereal and my coffees cold in another
room and I don't know where it is day 2
we have a classic waking up bed photo I
woke up with makeup and hair done
because you know sometimes when you're
an Instagram mom it just like happens in
your sleep and you wake up with your
hair and makeup done I can't find any
matching PJ's why do I bother making the
bed so at this point in the shoot the
kids were done they did not want to hold
still they didn't want to be a part of
this hi okay Jackson you're being a
little crazy and so I'm not gonna be
able to get you a slushy up you're being
crazy would you like a treat you don't
like this shoot me neither
there were slim pickins for a usable
photos here this was a gnarly part of
the shoot I'm coming up with today's
post trying to think of some captions I
lurked around and scream a little bit to
get some in spell and I saw this phrase
basking in the Bliss and I really liked
that I think that's something I'll keep
in my back pocket but this is the best
part is that I'm posting these like
perfect photos today with this blissful
caption and really I just am like way
overdue to wash my hair and I'm still in
my pajamas and I've already yelled at my
kids twice today
so this captions a little shorter
because you know I want to do a mix
basking in the bliss of waking up with
my little hashtag Sunday Funday hashtag
let them be little just let them do
their thing don't horse them to Satan
this photoshoots if they don't want to
be in
now we realized after the shoot that we
didn't get any food pictures and I
really wasn't willing to like sit and
slave over a dish to take a photo so we
have a brilliant idea of using a stock
photo for my food picture of the week
you know something that my kids would
take one look at and throw in the trash
here's the caption Monday lunch keeping
things fun while making sure the kids
are nourished I've noticed the word
nourished and nourished it's like huge
across these accounts too they love fun
faces on their food what are your
favorite ways to keep mealtime exciting
hashtag wellness mom it's it was so
apparent that I didn't actually make
that day for how do we feel and going to
Coachella yeah might stop at Coachella
might go to high tea I was like one of
those hats like wicker type hats oh I
actually love these photos and that's
what makes me sad about posting them in
this week to have to put some stupid
caption under it oh it just drove me
nuts well you got a G :
there were a lot of slushie bribes at
this point do it for slushies think
about this look she's you get your drink
there are literally a hundred outtakes
of this photo that we could not use
because one kids looking away or one is
closing his eyes or I'm not looking in
the right direction it's hard to
coordinate three people and so the only
reason I got these photos is because a
photographer took them and he's just
snapping snapping snapping caption I
read this quote the other day at some
point your parents picked you up put you
down and never picked you up again
and I made a promise to myself that even
when I'm old and gray when my boys are
men and living on their own and even if
it's creepy I will never stop picking
them up
hashtag outfit of the day Oh day five
I'm so awkward it just kind of happened
on the fly while we were shooting and it
was actually John's idea to take one of
my crystals and get a really sultry
photo with it so we went outside and
we're getting this photo and in the
meantime to my left there's the trash
truck picking up everybody's trash on my
street the photo itself looks it looks
good and of the entire photo set this
was the only one that works because I
made a poop face in all the other ones
this caption nobody tells you how
vulnerable motherhood makes you it is so
rewarding
but equally stressful I found that I
need to meditate spend time with my
crystals and manifested with mantras
every morning to be the best mom I can
be hashtag manifestation mama
hashtag wellness and people really
really liked it this photo did the best
out of the entire week this one photo of
just me did better out of every photo
with my kids it's not a complete lie I
do love my crystals I don't really do
mantras I kind of just like work hard
day six I originally was just supposed
to have a drink in my hand and me and my
workout clothes but then they both
wanted drinks on the couch to be on our
jury and so it's kind of a weird picture
cuz it's a little disjointed it doesn't
make a lot of sense but whatever we got
that picture at the expense of my entire
house like this couch doesn't go here
it's separated from the
nothing is where it actually is in my
house
it doesn't look like a mess at all like
we can oh my god I'm so clean I'm really
proud of this caption do you ever wake
up and marvel at how blessed you are
that's how I felt this morning grateful
to wake up to one more day with my kids
grateful for our morning yoga together
grateful for their always smiling faces
real talk sometimes my kids cry and
disagree and I'm not always perfect
sometimes I just wear workout clothes
like today but at the end of the day
we're still still very blessed hashtag
real talk
hashtag and down-to-earth hashtag honest
motherhood oh maybe I went a little
overboard no day seven I was really
looking forward to this post because
it's a really iconic Instagram moment
ready one two three one more time who
can jump the highest when Susie Jackson
won not only are there hundreds of
outtakes because we couldn't coordinate
our jump very well but Jackson at one
point just left and he was done he like
walked away and did one to him can you
do this just for me please and we're
almost done just to hold you over they
go so here's the caption jumping into
the weekend like salsa dancer emoji who
else can't resist a quick photo shoot
with their littles before school
hashtag mom life be like yeah just a
casual photo in the morning you know I'm
not still in my pajamas when they go to
school we're all dressed like that now
that this week is over I have some
thoughts I feel really weird about it I
do love the photos I got I love them
their photos I will cherish but I wasn't
able to post genuinely about these
photos I was not saying that this was
taken by a professional I wasn't saying
that this was all from one photo shoot I
wasn't being real with my followers
would I do this again
know that the promise I made to myself I
will never pretend that I'm something
I'm not a huge reason for making this
video is because when I was 22
frantically thrown into motherhood I
wish that I had seen something like this
to just make me feel like I was doing
okay and make me feel like I was enough
I always say I'm the world's okay Islam
because being okay is enough you can
just be okay and that's enough you don't
have to be perfect so that's all I got
for today I'm Hannah and in the spirit
of being real here's a little
behind-the-scenes peek of this show it's
not always as seems right
I know if you guys have any thoughts on
this video leave them in the comments or
if you have ideas for future episodes
leave that in the comments as well and
that's it for this little mini season
guys it's been real till next time
[Music]